today everybody and welcome to this
week's show I'm reto Meier nervously I'm
rid of us this week we're gonna be
taking a look at newsreader apps so I
can keep up with that story about the
dingo and the baby and I'm gonna freakin
and all that stuff on the latest whiskey
news this week Oh
today we're looking at news apps news
Republic from Mobile's Republic and the
verdicts media I'm gonna be flying solo
today as Ian recovers from his
needlessly angriness will will then dig
a little deeper and learn some of the
tricks you can use to make your news
apps even more engaging and in
particular we're going to be looking at
how to use pre caching and analytics to
really serve up relevant timely news
without draining the battery or sucking
up all of your bandwidth so news apps
have always been amongst the most
popular apps on mobile so you'd expect
that at this point they were pretty well
polished and to a large degree this is
true there's a great range of polished
intuitive apps that deliver timely and
relevant news articles both in the form
of aggregators like news Republic or
single source optimized apps like the
verge and so these are the sorts of
things which we come to expect from any
decent news app these days it shouldn't
drain the battery it should deliver
timely relevant news and it should
really have an easy-to-use UI at this
point the expectations around the user
interface for a news app are pretty well
understood we've sort of moved beyond
that really simple sort of lift ListView
forced refresh type approach to
something much more engaging with rich
media and so that's the sort of things
which we're expecting from our apps now
that means that user expectations
because they're so much higher now it's
no longer good enough to have something
which is just a janky ListView that only
updates when you hit refresh these days
users are really expecting something
more refined something that really
stands out from the crowd you know or
it's but the work of but a moment to
head back to Google Play and find
something better something which has
more of the news that you want in a much
nicer user experience so there's a
variety of options to help your news app
stand out now some of my favorites
include a clever use of notifications
and the ability to customize my news
feed even without having to log in and
so these are some of the the additional
extras that we can really use to boost
your app so smart notifications
customization without logging in and of
course widgets as well having a nice
resizable engaging widget which is
becoming more and more a must-have for
your news apps
so let's take a closer look at two apps
in particular News Republic and the
verge before looking at how you can
implement some of these more advanced
features yourself now News Republic is
currently my go-to news source so it's
fair to say that I'm a fan as you can
see their landing page in Google Play is
pretty good although I do wish that they
change their icon to something a little
more distinctive rather than using this
variation of the old rounded square
approach particularly if they already
have a really distinctive logo and you
can see that within their logo in both
places here you know they've sort of got
this a news Republic icon and I think it
would be really interesting to sort of
explore that a little bit further and
see what they could do to make that a
bigger part of both the icon and the
overall feature graphic speaking of the
feature graphic it it's pretty good but
perhaps a little bit too detailed to
really work well when you shrink it down
into some of our smaller feature graphic
spots you'll be really interested to see
a variation here that's a little bit
more stylized perhaps losing the content
of the papers here while still
maintaining that same stylistic look and
feel similarly you know within the logo
itself and you know maybe having a
larger text dropping the the logo
specifically from the feature graphic I
think both of those things could tend to
make it a little a little bit more
engaging particularly as we make it
smaller but really that's nitpicking and
a lot of the comments that I have for
News Republic today are along those near
picky lines because it really is a
really well polished app and they've
done a great deal of work here to make
it something that works really really
well so this here is my news Republic
home screen and as you can probably tell
I've customized it a little with Google
Android and UK top stories all there on
the front page now if we switch to the
giant phone you can see that they've
implemented that yeah you can see
they've implemented a number of really
nice transition animations when
switching between topics so if I click
here on two top stories you'll see it
all sort of flies out before filling it
all in and you can see it's got that
nice intro in animation so everything
every time you move around the app
everything sort of floats and flies with
you which is really nice everything
slides in slides out and you can see
that again get rid of the interstitial
the interstitial ads do take longer to
longer to display which is interesting I
guess if I had to make a choice between
the ads taking too long to display all
the news articles I would prefer that
the news articles are faster and that is
the way that it works though those
interstitials can be a little bit
frustrating at times so let's have a
look you can also see that once you're
within a particular topic they've
implemented sort of us or well once
you're reading each particular article I
should say you know you get the the
first time through you get told how to
interact with it which is it's probably
a good thing and you can see here
they've got the standard view pager
model for switch swiping between apps
which is really nice and up here at the
top here you can see the disappearing
reappearing tab headers so you can see
how far through a particular topic you
are which is really nice this sort of
follows their standard UI guidelines
while putting its own sort of
personalized take on that and of course
probably one of the most impressive
animations that they've got within the
app is their signature topic search
cloud that's implemented really nicely
so if I click up here
they're their search cloud icon and you
can see I get this really nice sort of
search cloud for all of the all of the
topics which are discussed within a
particular article so you can scroll
along here and then sort of use this the
way you would sort of scroll Wikipedia
and say oh actually I want to I want to
look at Google articles you click on
that and it will take you straight to
that sub list of of the Google stuff and
he can sort of do this as you're going
within each topic or within each each
article to further dig deep dig within
sort of that topic group and they've
actually got a few different approaches
here so you can have sort of a square or
you can have a scrolling sort of hoop I
suppose you'd say so they've got some
really nice animations here and it's it
really creates a really rich and
engaging experience which can really
encourage user to keep exploring within
the app which is a really key thing
within a news app you really want to
keep people jumping from article to
article reading as much
possible without sort of exiting your
app because their border they've just
come to they've read what they've come
to look at now in particular I think
news Republic does two things to really
difficult things really well so if we
switch back to the slides I'll
demonstrate what I'm talking about
beautiful so what you can see first off
they've implemented a really excellent
breaking news notification this doesn't
trigger too often for me maybe two three
times a day max so it's not intrusive it
doesn't make me feel as those running in
the background draining my battery all
the time but it does pop up and it does
remind me of breaking news as it happens
so it and then the actual implementation
of the notification is really really
good it's got a nice it's a rich
notification straight off so it's got an
image it has a generous snippet of news
so I can actually read what that
breaking news headline is and not just
the headline but actually sort of the
that lead the article lead to know
whether it's something which I want to
read further and what's what they've
done really well to get that bonus point
is that they've actually let me interact
with it directly from the notification
so you can see I can share it directly
from here or indeed indicate my mood the
way that this article makes me feel
which is another kind of killer feature
for news Republic here
they really encourage users to signal
the mood evoke by each article and they
let me do this without having to log in
so basically once I start up I can log
in I can choose to give them printed
credentials so that my preferences
persisted across devices and logins but
without having to do anything I can
straightaway start to interact and tell
them what my mood is and why is this
important well this lets them then
customize the things which I want to
hear about so my breaking news
notifications even the news feed itself
can all be optimized around the articles
which I interact with in particular it
gives you an idea of what kind of an
article it is what the people are
surprised angry sad happy which is kind
of useful in art of itself but apart
from that it's just a signal that people
are interested enough in a particular
article to engage with it so that gives
them really useful analytics that they
can use for a number of different things
now they can use that feedback to
either choose which notifications I'm
using or to customize the feed directly
now overall I think news Republic have
done have done these things really
really well there's really little jank
there so I really seldom find myself
waiting for images or articles to
download and the UI offers some really
unique features such as their subject
cloud without deviating too far from the
standard UI guidelines I never feel like
I'm lost within the app I'm sure of how
to do something or how to get somewhere
it's all where I expect it to be with
the occasional happy surprise of
something I wasn't expecting but I'm
happy to see now there are a couple of
areas where I'd like to see them adhere
a little more closer to the UI guide and
in particular it's really centered
around the action bar so you can see
here that they've created their own
action bar implementation which is
totally fine and understandable if you
want to have backwards compatibility and
not have to have too many different
versions of the app but some of their
choices are a little bit jarring to an
experienced Android user so in
particular the overflow menu is pretty
non-standard you can see here the size
of each menu item is slightly too large
separator lines are a little too dark
and all the text is right aligned which
is kind of off they should all be left
aligned and they've added icons which is
really non-standard so there's nothing
particularly wrong about the way this
looks except that it doesn't look the
way I expect it to so when I hit it it's
kind of creates this cognitive
dissonance moment of like oh okay this
isn't what I was expecting and so
whenever you're sort of surprising your
users with something they're not
expecting that can kind of break them
out of their engagement make them sort
of double
second-guess themselves almost it's like
oh did I do something wrong I was
expecting this to happen and something
else did you want to avoid those
circumstances where you're forcing users
to question their own behavior as that's
going to make them less confident make
them less willing to explore your app
and find some of the hidden gems and in
fact it goes a little one step further
with in the action bar itself you can
see that once you go beyond the the menu
to the actual action bar icons in
particular the mood and share icons
they're also a little non-standard
they're a bit too dark the overflow menu
item itself looks a lot like the
standard overflow menu but isn't quite
it it's too dark the dots are slightly
too big so again is we're talking really
variation but just enough to be a little
bit disconcerting so it's fair to say
that all this has been pretty nitpicky
but it's it's small details like this
that are kind of like having sand in
your bathers it's it's small but
constantly irritating so it would be
great to see see the team perhaps you
know work on those things but overall a
really fantastic app like I said might
go to news app every day so I'm a big
fan
now the verge as opposed to news
Republic which is a Content aggregator
the verge is a single source news app
that effectively wraps a popular tech
news site The Verge now we figured that
the verge spends enough time talking
about us that it might be fun to talk a
little bit about them so we'll start off
with their landing page which is great
it's got a distinctive logo whichever
unrecognised
and this feature graphic is really
standout now personally I think they may
have overdone the padding and
transparency a little bit so that the
actual logo and words are a little bit
small on the on the feature graphic here
I'd think about making that a little
more opaque and a little bit bigger just
so that when we shrink it down to some
of the smaller feature slots on a phone
it's still legible and recognizable now
single source apps tend to be a bit of a
mixed bag it's not uncommon to see
companies having an intern wrap their
RSS feed in a ListView and call it a day
and because people are you know
passionate readers of a particular site
they will download the app and use it no
matter what the the UX and UI is but
it's just not going to give them a great
experience and you've got to remember
that your app your Android app your
mobile app is a representation of your
website of your brand more importantly
so if you're going to go to the effort
of building an app you need to make sure
that it's something that represents your
brand in a positive way good news is
that the verge have done that
it is it is a good app they've done a
great job it's a it's a simple design
but very intuitive as it should be one
of the advantages of a single source app
like this is that you don't need to
figure out how to incorporate lots of
different sections from lots of
different news sources with potentially
different styles of writing different
styles of layout different styles of
imagery it all comes from your site so
you can be much more aggressive in your
assumptions as to the way you'll be
getting the information
way that that information should be
displayed so you can see right off the
bat they've separated the app into three
sections using a standard view pager
that works really well so you can swipe
between those there's sort of three main
topics and again this front page is
really nice and engaging you've got big
rich graphics particularly the top story
has that full bleed you know image in
the background in fact it may even be
worth considering doing that more you
know if you have that ability if you
have the ability to know what graphics
you're gonna get and what format that
they're in because it's your site it can
create a really engaging experience if
you make that front page just graphics
graphics graphics full bleed with with
headline text over the top now you do
need to be careful to weigh that up
against readability it's no use having a
great-looking front page if no one can
read the articles if that's the point
but it's something to consider a perhaps
trying to make that what we've got here
for the lead article more common
throughout the ListView they've also
implemented the draw pattern the right
way which is always nice to see and this
is an alternative here they've used it
as an alternative for hiding options
that you might otherwise expect to see
in the overflow menu I think that works
really well particularly for the
additional navigation options going
between sections and so on it really
lets them have that really clean front
page I was just the three swipers rather
than having sort of endless different
sections but I'm not sure it's the right
place for things like account and about
I can see that you've put them here so
that they you know everything all the
navigation opportune to earn in one
place but personally I think they would
be better off back in the overflow menu
away from the rest of the navigation so
that this stays as clean as possible I
think that's a really good theme overall
whenever you're sort of building that
navigation structure for your app is you
want to try and give people as few
options as possible whenever possible so
there are things like account and about
which need to be in the app and if
people want them they'll find them but
this is a good example where they may be
better off away from sort of this other
more standard navigation there's a lot
of really nice touches in the app I
particularly like the way that they've
handled comments and updates for stories
really intuitive that you've got things
like if there are updates to the stories
then the actual ListView will have those
updates underneath and you're able to
swipe through to get them really tidy
same with comments they've got a
separate page
using the standard action bar for adding
comments and and sort of a standard
ListView for reading them looks really
nice now this may be one or two
exceptions to things which which are
done the right way and I think most
notably is once you have sort of drilled
into a topic and you're reading an
article it's not possible to swipe
between the articles within a topic the
way that we saw earlier in news Republic
worked really well so that'd be really
nice to see something like that and the
reason for that is you know I don't want
to have to navigate navigate back up to
the topic it sort of breaks that flow
and it's back to what I was saying
earlier when you're building a news app
you really want to keep people reading
as long as possible and every time they
have to click it's one more step it's
that little bit longer so you want to
reduce the number of clicks between any
given action for user to get what they
want and so that ability to sort of
swipe through articles the way that you
would flip pages of a newspaper here's a
really good metaphor and it's it's one
which people are used to from reading
whether it be books magazines or
newspaper this idea of sort of getting
to a section and then just being able to
swipe through article after article is
really familiar so I think it'd be
really great to see something like that
implemented here using a viewpager and
this sort of segues nicely into the
first of my more generic recommendations
for building engaging news apps now
number one is you really want to be
using analytics now I've highlighted
here the analytics and Google Analytics
for Android applications of website but
really it can be this it can be
something homegrown it can be something
else entirely
but what you want to be doing is
tracking really closely the actions that
your users are taking this can be
completely anonymized it's not important
that you understand you know who it is
and what they've done really you just
want to get a glimpse into how things
are working which topics are popular
which articles are popular which
articles are being fully read which
topics are people reading all the
articles in that's going to give you a
lot of really rich information that you
can use to customize that feed and make
that news more and more relevant know
sorry so the best way to do this is just
the first time the app starts up to
assign it a UUID just a random
universally unique identifier so that
you're able to keep track of what people
are doing in a way that allows you to
customize their newsfeed accordingly you
can do that in a couple of ways so once
you've got that information and you
understand what someone's reading habits
are and it's important as well to make
sure that people understand that you're
doing this you know so that they know
that you are keeping track of what
they're reading if you plan to do it in
a way that is personalized to them so
first off you can customize the
notifications and potentially their
widget content so these are the things
which you're pulling out to specifically
highlight to them either on their home
screen widget or within these broadcast
alert notifications now this is really
important because it lets you make some
tailor that content to something that
they're likely to want to see and this
is really important for notifications if
you're going to be popping something up
interrupting their flow you want to make
sure it's something that they're going
to be interested in so understanding
what topics they've selected what
articles they tend to read is a really
powerful tool for being able to do that
now you can take this a step further and
aggregate all of the results server-side
and this may in fact be an even better
option in some cases then trying to make
it too customized to find out what is
everyone reading what are the articles
that everyone is clicking everyone is
reading through and potentially what are
they all sharing and that is probably
something which everyone else is going
to be interested in so you can take
those aggregated server-side results and
use it to use cloud-to-device messaging
to ping everyone that this is an article
that they may want to read and pop up a
notification accordingly now you can
then expand this beyond sort of a single
article to help decide which articles to
prefetch now we've talked about
prefetching before particularly for
something like news it's a really great
way to help reduce latency improve
offline support and reduce the battery
cost of getting those regular updates
it's really a way of you being able to
figure out what is the user going to
need in the next two to five minutes or
get it all now so then as soon as they
click on something it's already there
they don't have to wait at all there's
also a significant battery cost
associated with turning on the cell
radio in order to
download things so you want to try and
bundle all of that together and
prefetching is a great way of being able
to take all of the articles which you
think they may read pre downloading them
so that you don't have to do it each
time they click one now if you know what
articles are topics you do user is as
likely to actually read including the
frequency at which they're likely to
read it you stand a great chance of
downloading the right data at the right
time and really have a dramatic impact
on battery life while also reducing that
latency to nearly zero so that lets you
aggressively prefetch and making sure
that you always have fresh articles to
read and reducing that latency when you
click a headline so it's a really great
approach and you can see here a code
snippet which lets you vary the amount
of data that you're downloading based on
the cell radio connection that you have
which really boils down to the faster
the radio the more data you should
download when you're prefetching so now
that you're using analytics and
prefetching you run the risk of draining
the battery due to to to frequent Radio
state transitions so to minimize this
you need to bundle all your transfers as
much as possible now analytics is a long
game you don't need to your algorithms
don't need to be working out you know
every click how does this change you
know the next thing that we download it
really wants to be working on large
corpuses views of data so there's no
particular urgency to getting those
current usages those clicks back to the
server which means that you want to
batch them up and upload them at the
same time as you're going to do other
more time-sensitive transfers so using a
general pattern like this one you can
ensure that you're pre-empting every
next prefetch so if you're if user
clicks on a headline which you haven't
already downloaded you're going to need
to ping the server and grab that content
that's a great time to initiate the next
prefetch as well so the next bunch of
articles that the user may be reading as
well as then uploading all of your
analytics data so the trick here is to
always try and reduce the number of
times you turn on the radio to initiate
a transfer while still avoiding wasting
data so you don't want to download data
that you're never going to use but if
you do have the radio on it's a great
opportunity to try and download it as
much as you can so we've been talking
about doing everything anonymously which
is great and has some real advantages
but there are always advantages to
actually knowing who you'll use it
so with the new Google+ sign-in for
Android available as part of Google Play
services you can carry preferences
between devices without your users
needing to create yet another username
and password and because it's social you
can do clever things like customize the
news feeds which are being displayed to
each user based on what their friends
are reading or what their friends are
finding interesting so it's a great way
of being able to do that sort of you
know dynamic social sharing as
frictionless as possible so our next
step is to take a closer look at today's
apps and see how close they are to being
pure Android to do that we're going to
pass them through each of these standard
pure Android check lists and the apps
today we're actually pretty good so I
think they stand an excellent chance of
getting into this category and we'll
certainly be working with the developers
to try and help them better understand
some of the subtleties which which we're
not able to to fully describe within our
sort of 30 minute allocation so we'll be
getting in touch with these guys and
hopefully we'll see some updates in the
near future until then you can find our
existing pure Android collection at
bitly slash pure Android and you can
nominate your app for consideration by
adding it to our Trello page just search
for app clinic Trello and it will take
you right there now we're going to be
back later in the week to have a look at
podcast creation apps but the Android
design in action team are going to be
taking a break tomorrow so there'll be
no no Android design in action this week
unfortunately but they will be back next
week so until Friday I'm reto Meier and
this has been the App clinic